et lille juste pas vous écouter du rap
ou pas
20 % 20 % 80 % de ce qui est produit
dans le rap ça veut rien dire c'est la
merde quand je dire pourquoi parce que
ils véhiculent de la haine
à la base l'europe vient du hip hop le
hip hop à la base c'était pour s'amuser
entre copains tournoyer sur les
trottoirs des jeux comme ça et puis là
il ya des gens moyenne il ya des gens il
ya des gens qui ont pris l'europe en
otage et puis qui sont mis à divulguer
de la haine sur la société
[Applaudissements]
c'est un avertissement
alors je sais que vous adorez drame on
peut pas dire le rap c'est de la merde
chez mes parents moi même si elle adore
hugo tsr elle écoute pas un ego tsr elle
trouve que c'est formidable donc
j'écoute les textes avec est c'est vrai
que je suis parfois d'accord je trouve
que comme le dit finkielkraut parfois
quand je lis ou j'entends on va te faire
[ __ ] ou si tu mouilles pas mme
mollard vente à châtel tout ça moi ça me
choque alors là oui la messe à 15 heures
alors qui met pas plein vous avez pris
au passage particulier la run et les
pires des pays hors ocde
y'a pas pire mime enfin il ya pire mais
malgré tout c'est aussi une image du rap
où la femme malgré tout est un peu quand
même renvoyer un truc d'objets qu'il ya
aussi des films de cul pardon si t'aime
pas tu regardes pas si c'est moi
oui mais absolument la pornographie il
ya un tas alors ne crachera non mais je
veux dire ces deux centres si on n'aime
pas de musique qu'on écoute pas mais
absolument
rien n'est pas mal de rappeurs qui vous
ont choqué jaune oui certaines d'orelsan
sur marie trintignant d'accord intimidé
je crois à l'époque oui j'avais trouvé
ça super dur et super violent après y'en
a qui disent quoi c'est un peu limite ça
joue mais moi je vois là je trouve que
parfois c'est parfois c'est un peu
c'est vrai mais moi parfois je trouve
que la récession quand même très objet
c'est vrai oui moi ça me choque en tant
que femme voilà l'homme et ses cheveux
pâles interdit mais ça vient d'expliquer
et de la géologie et que je préfère que
ma fille l'écouté je lui dit qu'est ce
que tu en penses allait me dis moi moi
ça me choque parce qu elle a une éduquer
les jeunes et ceux qui écoutent un il
écoute avec un esprit critique aussi
mais oui il
y en a qui sont aussi premier degré oui
par exemple à 9h sur air qu'elles n'ont
donc ça passe ça valait vraiment ce à
quoi servons tu voulais dire à lui selon
lui les curieux donc l'écouter tout ce
qui est en bas il ya des jeunes qui se
reconnaissent beaucoup dans des paroles
durable ça parle de où ils ont grandi ça
parle d'histoire moi moi pendant le
confinement j'écoute j'ai découvert jul
par le confinement de tout son album et
quand on voit ce que vend booba comme
disque et quand on voit ce que venger
jusque devant jude s'est pas séparé la
direction jules non c'est pas c'est pas
les artistes français qui est artiste
français qui vendent le plus c'est booba
et c'est jude celles qui vendent le plus
donc il faut écouter faux-pas d'idiot la
buba yamini monsieur la elvis presley il
dit que c'est de la merde c'est pas de
ma mère parce qu'il y aura autant de
gens qui achètent rsa donc faut pas faux
pas mais
la droite paie mais là pour dire c'est
pas ma cible j'aime pas
héraultais à eric tu as déjà écouter les
paroles de booba alors j'ai écouté bon
pour ça j'ai bien aimé les clips à les
clips sont bien remontés les belles
images et où j'ai eu un clip avec une
gamine dans les bras à tous j'ai
beaucoup aimé les images franchement tu
as une bonne équipe de production des
retours maintenant la zizanie
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi que tu chantes
compris moi ce que c'est qu'un vrai
chanteur
[Applaudissements]
cavani qui se voulait dire
non j'avais pas fini ma chance et bon
merci m r cyril voilà qui nous a
[Applaudissements]